i've got two girl that need them
stealing no but you have to wear them
now then put them on i don't have to put
in the lashes
lump it slump it my brothers don't eat
crumpets
[Music]
my brothers don't eat crumpets united
set already
welcome back to lv's full fit roulette
challenge
i'm telling you now this one air
it's a different level ruby that the
superstars have turned up today you know
we have
christopher savage also known as
branches don't piss man
off their man there when the sketches
have you seen our moves
then we've got diesel the comedian he
sticks it on you it's long for you
and then finally but not least we've got
white yardy stand up comedian
different guy at different levels listen
all i'm gonna say to you is now
today is legendary we've got superstars
in the building
yo mandem are you telling me different
settings you know this is legendary
settings today you know
i'm glad i'm back yeah
you said you just say this drink is
drunk in me a little bit full
blowns hi i'm chris
um this is the comedian i'm one of the
funniest guys in england
i'm handsome i'm beautiful and i'm sexy
and i'm a mandom you're not prepared for
today though yeah the man is drinking
that's why
i'm bugged i'm not involved you know i
really really wanted to
um no no no you're from the hot fam
don't talk up like that for camera yeah
we're talking to man from the home yeah
i'm bugged i'm burnt
you're one christopher's two yards free
who am i why you are the um
international comedian
don't know the white jamaican yes that's
your numbers yeah yeah
it's only because it's there in it it
makes sense your one is to your tree all
right
number four number four is a mystery
number yeah so
i might just run anything in that one
there it could be anything basically you
just spin this
and if it lands on your number you've
got a guy in the box pick up stand out
tv as well
so if you land on him he has to say you
know if you land on him then he has a
guy in the box
okay land on you your number you guys
never played never played games in your
life isn't it
a game player
man grew up in serious times
dude upon everybody because i'm a savage
i'm called christopher savage i know
i'm presenting this time so yeah i know
unfortunately
everyone would love me to be there again
for a madness can't speak english
i didn't know how to say um
no not milk [ __ ] that i'm like a
terrorist or whatever it is all right
don't worry i'm going to do it now watch
i'm going to show everyone that i can
say it
one hour later lactose intolerant
now tell me i didn't say it tell me i
didn't say it thank you very much so
there you go everyone stay off my back
now when you see me
lacto it anyway allow it
ah it's yourself so you have to get in
the box
i say something to you when i first
watched the thing yeah you just had a
second spin
no i didn't you didn't
i am the host i'm gonna start putting my
foot down
take contestants number one's phone send
the dm saying what you like
the last person they were speaking to on
instagram
okay so you're number one yeah so you
can't do that so now
you get to pick from christopher or
yardy
phone you want to take and do that to
i'll do anything why you can't tell me
what for anything bring the [ __ ] bring
the toes
what does he have to do he asked a guy
in your phone i think it said and um
say what he wants to say to the last
person you dm'd last person
oh am i looking forward to today
um not really
i said nah gonna a problem if you come
back out you see you agua now
is it were you gonna message her though
let me see what kind of conversation she
had before with her
yeah you just said that i said nothing
just laughing faces
hi do you you know
what herpes oh my god the man said
herpes no
you can't do that to me hi do you know
what herpes look like
can i show you a pic of my seed bag so
you can see and
can tell me if
herpes
oh my god can i show you mine too oh my
god
i'm not a doctor sorry oh ski the sad
face and the ants
like that now can i take them back no no
no no no no no
wait spin that's the wheeler i hope it
ends on your
ass clothes
two raw eggs
[Laughter]
enough yeah i'm gonna vomit yeah
right boom mysteries you see it there
what's the worst being what's ever
happened to you in your life oh that's
not that's not hard man
you woke up in the morning feeling yours
huh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
scroll down contestants number one's
phone and send a message to any female
saying something of your
the thing out choice him you'd set
yourself up there i don't know what was
happening
no he asked the question though
[Laughter]
can i have your it's called forfeit
roulette so what's the forfeit
that is the forfeit no that doesn't make
sense
do i think i'm gonna be all right with
the forfeits okay um
yeah i am because if there's a forfeit i
don't like i'm not doing it
no one can't force me do it when a bad
man can i have
i just don't know why you went in the
box why did you get in that box
whoever did this yeah you got phone
issues it's coming out
yeah you got caught by your girl
my phone's dead anywhere i don't know
how to get my
i can't remember my pin why are you
setting me up i don't want that contact
i want someone else no you you your
choice yeah yes thank you
come on i come at them you must have
come out
man send a message to
any female saying something get me to
the context
i'm understood about putting a battery
for no reason so imagine when you say
about me now can be cooley
i've got a time limit five
she might find that fun she might find
that now it's like a fantasy thing for
her
harry harrier
yo you know so after you know the
thought of sniffing your knickers i fell
asleep
and woke up feeling i got to
can we agree that just send nice
stuffing out the same
yeah yeah okay
that's my worst enemy that's my worst
enemy in there
my worst enemy what i just see right
there you got new bad man while coming
eyelashes for the rest of the show i'll
do a tablespoon of
paprika oh then do the paprika in it
that's light right now i'm smoking more
to lashes
i got two girl that need them still
about no but you have to wear them now
then put them on i don't know how to put
in the lashes
there's a bit of man in there somewhere
and there's no woman here and i'm not
making no man put that that's like
that's going out so we're going to do
the perfect no no i think this
jeans so you got [ __ ] up you need to
have your team set it out all right
we're just going to go back in the box
no i'll try and put the lashes on no one
had put no lashes on me
no man ain't pulling me there
yeah but if you see a man with a beard
and a rascal dress
that's harry the director he was
directing it to this way
this is lb's forfeit dog yeah not
harry's coming out fighting
[Laughter]
yeah are you again that spin always goes
for one for some odd reason
all right so why are you defending me
now i've done it
[Laughter]
is it black on the screen a picture of a
doctor's waiting room put it in this
insta story and put the location as a
sexual health clinic
do you know what that could have done to
my reputation that was like picked in
picked in and i picked it that's like
pizza he's got the same language as
rugrats
i see the yeah and the eyelashes that's
like saying all right
you want me to fist you or i'll give you
a big
blood clot of cone dildo in your ass
thing how can we ignore the phone hub
thing oh my god man's got phone number
freaking visit buffalo with
small waves weird [ __ ]
one in um
i can't believe this is really what's
going on today why would you do me again
why couldn't you just
cover uh i didn't do you in the first
place
what what did you put in that punch my g
what the [ __ ] is in this
gay juice
q is long kiss my teeth and my dick is
on fire
wow anyone can hook me up with a link
for tablets
[Applause]
you have to run that can't run someone
say um candy something
it wasn't it wasn't yeah
oh
that's racist why choose the white man
[ __ ]
chip on your shoulder he's got a little
chip
chocolate chip it's a chocolate
he's straight down the line with what
yes there's different forms of
intelligence and i can't see one in you
you ready go on okay four
can't you do even forfeit now yeah man
that yes this is it yeah you pick it
yeah
yeah you got to take a batter out of a
red onion
no you would have to do it no i don't
what yeah you sweat a part of the game
that is
[Laughter]
ah no that's like a [ __ ]
angers are good for the heart system
is that good for the heart system now
buy it and chew it i want some little
quarteting
no but all right properly man
crunchy it sounds like it tastes nice
though a little crunching that must be
nasty man he's got onion in there for
[ __ ] days you put that in his pocket
that was disgusting man listen harry you
know you're gonna have to drink the eggs
then
all right i've joined the rules have
changed so i've now joined the game now
that means i spin yeah oh you spin all
right cool go on and anyone can get
another
no no no eat two pieces of macro
or take a neck slap from a contestant
number two so he's either got eight
he's gonna eat the macro what's
disgusting that's probably for days and
nights
that one they look like it like like the
mackerel i wet itself i got kids i'm
never gonna allow my kids
[ __ ] [ __ ] slapped me in my neck he
has two pieces
so this that's one piece
slap boom so either way if him can't do
it i'm still an older slap
like david blaine
is here i'll tell you now i've been
known for my next selection
see my neck slaps them
it's like getting the judge the judge
sent you to eight years
and you're trying to speak you're still
going to get the eight
i need a gum shield why not i might bite
my tongue
i might bite my tongue can you
technically tell me when you're going
yeah i'm gonna let you know
just let me know did i tell you
yeah that remember that day when we was
at the um the bbc
thing with uh big nasty and and um hax
was there
and you had the mickey mouse outfit on
yeah and i'll tell you not to put that
on
oh you remember yeah
extra extra hot sauce i can't do sauce
i can't do soda why if they save this
killer one for
me why is god like this because it was
never like this god went nut this though
nah the whole game no no no the whole
game i've been quiet
i've been calm i've been relaxed i have
not said nothing to no one i've tried to
sit in
everyone else take the show and relax
and just sit back watch the star dude
i thought i wrote and she is the lucky
number yeah because you never get
touched the whole game
listen god no make mistake it's gross
god no sleep
[Laughter]
how am i going to get through this one
can you see this
i don't you could you want to read it
bro
that is the burning hot one i've seen in
[ __ ] that
general that's why you name lv jenna
ragland now yeah when you put
it goes
[Laughter]
every show they don't like you i'm gonna
have to have the bucky ready
no no no you have to do in the bar so
it's
everything just feels good depends what
kind of dude you do
you don't even look dark skinny and i
get perry tamer when i got
hey you understand stay tuned to the
next episode
lumpy slump it my brothers don't eat
crumpets
you